[Music]
Edward
s a
19 is
foreign
foreign
parole
is unique
thank you Mr President
yesterday the secretary
Secretary General said and I quote
the U.N Charter is clear
any annexation of a state or territory
by another state resulting from the
threat or use of force is a violation of
the principles of the U.N Charter and
international law unquote
that very violation is what we are
confronted with today
the United States has proposed a
resolution with Albania to condemn the
illegal so-called referenda held in
Ukrainian territory
the resolution is straightforward
it condemns these illegal referenda it
calls on all states to not recognize any
altered state of Ukraine
and it requires that Russia withdraw its
troops from Ukraine immediately
we have heard from many of you over the
course of the past few days that you
felt the process was rushed
let me be clear
what was rushed was the Russian illegal
act to Annex Ukrainian territory
as a council we had to respond
colleagues this is exactly what the
security Council was made to do
defend sovereignty protect territorial
Integrity promote peace and security the
United Nations was built on an idea that
never again would one country be allowed
to take another's territory by force
that path we agreed leads to history's
most horrific outcomes
Russia's attempted annexations are
without a Shadow of Doubt
exactly that
we're talking about a U.N member state
a security council member
attempting to Annex part of another
through Force
the outcomes of these sham referenda
were predetermined in Moscow and
everybody knows it
they were held behind the barrel of
Russian guns
time and time again we have seen the
Ukrainian people fight for their country
and their democracy
the Ukrainian civilian Who removed a
Russian landmine with his bare hands the
ukrainians abroad who returned to fight
for their country
the soldiers sacrificing their lives to
stop Russian advances
Putin miscalculated the resolve of the
ukrainians
the Ukrainian people have demonstrated
loud and clear they will never accept
being subjugated to Russian rule
and so the United States will never
recognize any territory Russia attempts
to seize or allegedly Annex as anything
other than part of Ukraine
Secretary General guterres has said the
same he said yesterday again and I quote
any decision to proceed with the
annexation of donask luhansk her son and
zaparizia regions of Ukraine would have
no legal value and deserves to be
condemned let me repeat that deserves to
be condemned
the Secretary General then said it would
when it went against and I quote again
the purposes and principles of United
Nations it is a dangerous escalation in
his words it has no place in the modern
world it has no place in the modern
world
colleagues we all have an interest in
defending the sacred principles of
sovereignty and territorial integrity
in defending peace in our modern world
all of us understand the implications
for our own borders our own economies
and our own countries if these
principles are tossed aside
this is also bigger than any one nation
large or small it's about our collective
security
our Collective responsibility to
maintain International Peace and
security
not just for ourselves but for the world
this is what this body is here to do
we are the first line of defense for the
U.N Charter and we must demonstrate that
we take that defense seriously we must
show that the council can work despite
the actions of one permanent member this
is not a moment to stand on the
sidelines this is a moment to stand up
for the U.N Charter for its values for
its principles and Forest purposes
and if Russia chooses to Shield itself
from accountability then we will take
further steps in the general assembly to
send an unmistakable message to Moscow
that the world is still on the side of
Defending sovereignty and protecting
territorial integrity
earlier today we saw Putin celebrate
this clear violation of international
law
he threw a party on Red Square to Pat
himself on the back for these illegal
referenda he's gloating and reminiscing
about the Soviet Empire and stated that
this was just the beginning
as we all sit in this chamber and
solemnly consider this resolution Putin
is instead boastfully shoving our shared
shared values in our faces
it's time we stand up to defend our
Collective beliefs together
in defense of these principles that we
hold dear the United States is putting
forward this resolution with Albania
in defense of all countries to have the
right to be safe from Invasion and
annexation
we are voting yes and in defense of the
world's Collective peace and security we
urge you to vote Yes too
let us show Putin the resolve of this
Council thank you Mr President
is
thank you president
colleagues
Russia's annexations further jeopardize
the prospects for peace and they
fundamentally undermine the purposes and
the principles of the United Nations
the area Russia is claiming to Annex
is more than 90
000 square kilometers
this is the largest forcible annexation
of territory since the Second World War
there is no middle ground on this
it is in the end
a very simple question of Principle as
the Secretary General has said
as members of the security Council with
the responsibility of maintaining
International Peace and security and
upholding the UN Charter
we must condemn Russia's actions and
vote in favor of this resolution
thank you
merci is declarations
foreign
foreign
foreign
history
is
secretary
business
organizations
foreign
no referendum was necessary
foreign
[Music]
do not see other states as equal
Partners
will be able to form their own unbiased
view of this emerging situation make the
right choice thank you very much for
your opinion
I will not
resolution
draft resolutions
stroke 720 please raise your hand
thank you
because
against it because
microphone resolution those against the
driver please raise your hand
s
resolution
one against
four abstentions
member of the council
after the vote
to Albania museums thank you Mr
President this is another dark day for
the security Council for the United
Nations and for the world
the security Council was again taken
hostage on the same issue and by the
same country
and was prevented from action acting on
one of the most important issue on its
agenda
once more Russian misused a unique
privilege that the U.N Charter the very
one that Russia with its actions is
surrendering to Pieces has granted to
permanent members to maintain peace and
security and uphold the international
law and not to block the council when
the world needs it
the text proposed today was about the
most fundamental issues and principles
that bound us together in the United
Nations in the multilateral world
the preservation of territorial
Integrity the sovereignty and
Independence of a U.N member state
as it has done since 24th of February
Russia chose to stand in total
opposition with international law
with its own commitments with all the
repeated calls from every corner of the
world to stop its actions change course
and work for peace
today's vote showed once more that
Russia is and remains isolated in its
actions and with its positions
today's vote showed that Russia never
wanted peace never wanted dialogue
what it wanted was only a part of the
territory of Ukraine which now claims
that it's its own
will not accept it and will not
recognize any of the consequences of the
Russia's actions that go to the
detriment of Ukraine
colleagues
what is happening now in Ukraine should
be an alarming Bell for the entire world
we should not accept illegal annexation
of the territory of other countries
we reiterate the call of on all states
and international organizations not to
recognize any acquisition by the Russian
Federation of any part of the territory
of Ukraine and to refrain from any
action or dealing that might be
interpreted as recognizing any such
acquisition
we must be United and firmly condemned
this unacceptable behavior and stand in
defense of and support Ukraine
because in this way we defend the
rules-based international order
international law and the U.N Charter
we'll continue our fight in the ga and
we'll call on the general assembly to
defend the U.N Charter
and as as to the referred Russian Mantra
to draw artificial parallels with other
situations which have nothing to do with
Russia's aggression we have been clear
about it more than once and we are not
going to
identify such claims which are of the
same nature as there is no war in
Ukraine we have committed no crimes
there and we do and we do not want this
territory we trust everyone is today
more than ever eyes wide open and I
thank you
of India
thank you Mr President
India is deeply Disturbed
by the recent turn of developments in
Ukraine
we've always advocated that no solution
can ever be arrived at the cost of human
lives
we urge that all efforts are made by
concerned sides for the immediate
cessation of violence and hostilities
dialogue is the only answer to settling
differences and disputes however
daunting that may appear at this moment
the path to peace requires us to keep
all channels of diplomacy open
India's prime minister has unequivocally
conveyed this in his discussions with
world leaders including with the
presidents of the Russian Federation and
Ukraine
so has our external affairs minister in
his recent engagements at the general
assembly last week
India's prime minister has also
emphasized that this cannot be an era of
War
we therefore sincerely hope for an early
resumption of peace talks to bring about
an immediate ceasefire and resolution of
the conflict
India's position has been clear and
consistent from the very beginning of
this conflict
the global order is anchored on the
principles of the UN Charter
international law and respect for
sovereignty and the territorial
integrity
of all states
escalation of rhetoric or tension is in
no one's interest it is important that
pathways are found for a return to the
negotiating table
keeping in view the totality of the
evolving situation
India decided to abstain on the
resolution thank you
to the representative of Norway
president
we voted in favor of this resolution
the security Council has a
responsibility to act to prevent and end
acts of aggression atrocities and
certainly breaches of territorial
integrity
we deeply regret that this resolution
failed to be adopted due to a single
work member casting its veto
it is one that Russia an invading force
can also prevent Council action aimed at
ending its aggression
Moscow has launched an illegal process
of annexation of the Ukrainian regions
of the nesk luhansk Carson and saparita
the Secretary General was very clear
yesterday
affirming that any annexation of a
state's territory by another state
resulting from the threat or use of
force is a violation of the principles
of the U.N Charter and international law
we fully conquer
whatever outcome Russia announces in
Moscow today is contrary to
international law has no legal effect
and in no way changes Ukraine's
sovereignty within its internationally
recognized borders
the Russian Federation one of the five
permanent members of the security
Council has a clear responsibility to
respect the charter yet its action
related to Ukraine Cuts against
everything U.N membership is supposed to
stand for
with this action Russia is isolating
themselves from the global Community
rejecting multilateralism international
law and the principles and purposes of
the U.N Charter they also continue to
ignore the global effects they are
causing
president it is unacceptable that the
security Council has again been blocked
from taking action on this significant
threat to International Peace and
security
we are however assured that the general
assembly now will have the opportunity
to take up this grave and important
issue and we urge the Speedy production
of a special report on this use of the
veto
president the position on Norway is
clear we are fully committed to the
sovereignty Unity Independence and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine within
its internationally recognized borders
thank you
of China
foreign
tradition
s
I'm sorry Mr President China abstained
from voting on the draft resolution just
to put to vote I would like to make the
following statement in relation to the
China let me start again thank you Mr
President Mr President
from voting on the draft resolution
I would like to make the following
statement in relation to China's vote
China's position on the issue of Ukraine
is consistent and clear
the sovereignty and territorial
Integrity of all countries should be
safeguarded the purposes and principles
should be observed
legitimate security concerns of all
parties should be taken seriously
to the peaceful resolution of the crisis
should be supported
yeah
over seven months into the Ukraine
crisis the crisis
have had a wide range of negative
impacts
of prolonged and expanded crisis is also
worrying
We Believe China is deeply concerned
about this project we believe that
priority
why is to make every effort to
de-escalate the situation and guide the
parties to restart diplomatic
negotiations as soon as possible to open
the door to a political settlement with
legitimate concerns brought into the
negotiations
and viable options on the table
without the effort to achieve the early
ceasefire
third
the security Council
as the core of the international
collective security mechanism should
uphold objectivity and impartiality and
give priority to using the good offices
and the mediation tools converted by the
Union charter to play a responsible and
constructive role in the political
settlement of the Ukraine issue any
action taken by the security Council
well who should be truly conducive to
easing the situation and resolving the
crisis rather than intensifying
conflicts and exacerbating confrontation
and the interplay of various conflicts
and tensions over a long period of time
fans have shown that political isolation
functions and pressurization Fielding
the tensions and the block confrontation
will not bringing us
instead they will only worsen the
situation and make the issue more
complicated and intractable China costs
on all parties is it concerned to
exercise restraints refrain from actions
that exactly and leave space for
Solutions through diplomatic
negotiations
as a responsible country China has
always stood on the side of Peace we
will continue to play a constructive
role in easing the situation and
resolving the crisis thank you Mr
President
representative of the United Kingdom
thank you president
yet again
Russia has abused its veto to defend its
illegal actions
council members have voted in different
ways
but one thing is clear
not a single other member of this
Council
recognizes Russia's attempted illegal
annexation of Ukrainian territory
Russia's veto doesn't change that fact
the announcement by President Putin
today of the accession of the Ukrainian
regions of her son the parisia luhansk
and danetsk into the Russian Federation
has no legal effect
it is fantasy
Russia's Invasion needs to end
the world has made this clear for seven
months
yet Russia's response
has been further escalation
further mobilization
nuclear threats
and today
another callus attack
on a civilian Convoy in zaparesia
the sovereignty and territorial
Integrity of Ukraine is under attack
the International System
is being assaulted in front of our eyes
Russia will not succeed in this illegal
imperialist War
the only question is how much damage
they do how many lives they waste before
they realize that
thank you president
um
thank you Mr President
Ireland voted in favor of this
resolution
we did so because we believe there must
be a robust response from the security
Council to yet another blatant bleach of
the U.N Charter by the Russian
Federation in its war of aggression
against Ukraine
Ireland remains fully committed to the
sovereignty and the territorial
Integrity of Ukraine within within its
internationally recognized borders
earlier this week Ireland condemned the
Sham referenda conducted an occupied
Ukrainian territory by Russia or its
proxies
today we categorically reject the
so-called results of those illegal and
illegitimate referenda and announcements
purporting to an ex-ukrainian territory
they have no legal effect
as I said at our meeting on Tuesday this
is nothing more than a blatant land grab
by the Russian Federation
let me be clear Ukraine's borders have
not changed
the Sham referenda did not reflect the
popular or freely expressed will of the
Ukrainian people
they're they are illegal they violate
the U.N Charter they violate Russia's
obligations under international law and
they violate the law of occupation
president once again the Russian
Federation has shamefully used the
vehicle in a flagrant attempt to excuse
its own military aggression against
Ukraine a fellow member of our United
Nations
the shocking images of civilians killed
or injured near zapprovision this
morning our Stark reminder that it is
civilians who are paying the highest
price for Russia's senseless War
the use of this anachronistic veto in
these terrible and tragic circumstances
is simply reprehensible and undermines
the legitimacy of this Council in the
eyes of the watching world
however this veto will not prevent the
International Community from responding
to Russia's blatant breaches of
international law
this video will not deter us from
holding Russia accountable for its
actions
in accordance with resolution 76 262
Ireland now calls in the council to
submit a special report on the use of
the veto in this instance to the general
assembly thank you
Mercier
thank you Mr President Ghana voted in
support of the draft resolution as we
firmly believe in its objective to
uphold the rules of international law
and the principles and values of the
charter of the United Nations we regret
the unsurprising outcome of the vote and
the fact that once again the use of the
veto by the offending state has stood in
the way of the council's exercise of its
mandate to promote and maintain
International Peace and security
the conduct of the referenda and the
subsequent steps taken by the Russian
Federation to Annex the occupied
territories within the internationally
recognized borders of Ukraine in our
view are illegal and constitute serious
violations of the sovereignty political
Independence and territorial
independence of Ukraine
they are void and of no legal effect in
our view as well as that of many in the
International Community
as we have repeatedly stated in this
chamber it remains our principled
position not to recognize the
acquisition of territory by any state
through the threats or use of force
we believe that any attempt to
unilaterally delineate borders and for
that matter State territory is an
attempt to unravel the settled and
accepted Norms of behavior which have
ensured the relative stability of our
International System since this
organization was established to draw the
curtains on the era of conquest of
territory by Wars
we call on the Russian Federation to end
its aggression against Ukraine and
refrain from any further escalatory
action and embrace a new chapter of
Peace Corporation and friendly relations
which is required of all member states
in concluding my remarks I reaffirm
Ghana's firm commitment to respect the
sovereignty political Independence and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine within
its internationally recognized borders
and reiterate in that regard our
continuous support of efforts to help
bring an end to the world through
peaceful means I thank you
to the representative of Mexico
president
Mexico
which throughout is history
circumstances
in breach of the United Nations
according to the rules
explicitly in our organizations
sovereign
[Music]
thank you
Mexico Mexico
president of Brazil
thank you Mr President
Mr President
Brazil abstained on the draft proposed
by Albania and the United States
Brazil expressed its views on the
referenda in Ukraine at the meeting on
the 27th it is unreasonable to assume
that populations in areas of conflict
are able to freely Express their will
the results of such referenda under the
current circumstances
do not constitute a valid or Genuine
expression of the will of the local
populations and cannot be perceived as
legitimate
Brazil stands by the principle of
territorial Integrity of sovereign
states
we acknowledge the drafters efforts to
amend the text to make it more focused
and streamlined
Mr President on the resolution itself
we believe that its scope and language
do not favor an environment conducive to
a solution for the conflict in Ukraine
it is a repetition of the same dynamics
of the past months in which the council
cannot agree on any constructive action
concerning the conflict in Ukraine
besides the document presented to the
council members does not contribute to
the immediate goals of de-escalating
tensions negotiating a ceasefire and
starting peace negotiations
we also have a few observations on the
process
circulated draft with such short notice
for consultations with our capitals did
not allow member states to timely
Express their views and concerns
we missed a valuable opportunity of
engaging collectively and a transparent
manner making full use of our
consultation spaces in the security
Council
Mr President
this Council should now explore new
courses of action
in the last seven months the refusal to
consider alternatives did nothing to
bring about a political solution to the
conflict
on the contrary it has brought about
further escalation and fueled
counterproductive narratives in our
midst it is time to do what is expected
from us to find Solutions based on
straightforward dialogue and
constructive diplomacy with a
willingness to fully addressing the
concerns of all parties I thank you
for that statement
representative of Kenya
thank you Mr President
since the start of the war in Ukraine
Kenya has consistently called for
cessation of hostilities to allow for
dialogue leading to a stable European
security order
whether this is established now or
following a protracted war that can
escalate to an extreme danger to
International Peace and security a
negotiation is inevitable
it is critical to the world and
especially developing countries
suffering from increased food insecurity
and damaging economic Tamil that it be
undertaken now in a way that addresses a
security concerns of all parties
this resolution whether here in the
council or in the general assembly will
not solve this crisis
our affirmative vote is based on Kenya's
principled defense of the United Nations
Charter and in particular its protection
of the principle of sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of all member
states
our affirmative vote today is necessary
on principle but insufficient in
practically ensuring that the security
Council carries out its mandate we urge
all members to do more to find a path to
dialogue and diplomacy rather than turn
the council into an arena for the
continuation of conflict by diplomatic
means rather than its resolution
Mr President with this vote Kenya
reaffirms its recognition of Ukraine's
sovereignty territorial Integrity within
its internationally recognized borders I
thank you
declarations
thank you Mr President
the referenda held over the last week
amidst the ongoing armed conflict and
the announcement made earlier today
regarding the incorporation of four
regions into the Russian Federation are
serious developments in this conflict
they make finding a peaceful resolution
more difficult and they implicate the
territorial Integrity sovereignty and
Independence of a U.N member state
these are core principles of the United
Nations Charter Central to the peaceful
cooperative and productive relations
between states and essential for the
security and stability of all
these principles protect all states
large and small powerful and weak and
this has informed our vote today
the principle of self-determination is
also a fundamental principle enshrined
in the charter we all ratified
but any tensions between this principle
and the principles of territorial
Integrity sovereignty and Independence
need not amount to a zero-sum game
the developments of the last days
weren't a clear statement from the
council underlining the importance of
the fundamental principles of the
charter we have voted in favor of the
resolution for that reason although we
would have also liked more time to
engage in further edits to the text and
on the substance
but as we have continuously stressed in
this chamber the pathway towards a
peaceful resolution of this conflict
lies in solutions that involve both
sides coming to the table quickly
without preconditions and with the
support of trusted interlocutors we urge
both Russia and Ukraine to do so and I
know many around this table today and
outside share in this View
this war has gone on too long and
destroyed Too Many Lives resolving this
conflict is important not only for
Ukraine and Russia and both their
peoples but also for Global Peace and
security
we need to all stop escalation and help
create the conditions for peace We Stand
ready to work with all members of this
Council to find ways to effectively
address the root causes of this conflict
and to support a diplomatic pathway
forward
thank you
representative of the United Arab
Emirates
to the representative thank you Mr
President Mr President
abstained from the vote
foreign
Elizabeth
to join us
which once again
sovereign
[Music]
of Ukraine
well thank you Mr President
distinguished members of the security
Council
and I also recognize here the
representative of Russia in the
permanent seat of the Soviet Union
his lonely hand just raised against the
draft resolution
has again testified
to Russia's isolation
and his desperate attempts
to deny reality
and our common commitments starting from
the U.N Charter
Putin's Envoy has followed
in the footsteps
of his master in Moscow
where a puppet show has been organized
today in an attempt to deny the obverse
that the aggressive and adventurist
regime in Russia
is heading to its imminent defeat
I'm now going to elaborate on lies that
have nothing in common with reality
because the reality is quite different
in reality Putin has tried to grab
territories he does not even physically
control on the ground
in reality Ukrainian forces continue
their operations to liberate our
Sovereign territories
in reality at least 30 civilians have
been killed in 88 wounded following the
Russian selling of zapariza earlier
today
Russia persists in its genocidal
practices of killing ukrainians
torturing and oppressing them in the
occupied territories
therefore the only way to make all
ukrainians throughout this Sovereign
territory of Ukraine feel safe and under
the protection of their state is to
hoist Ukrainian Flags back throughout
occupied the bus Southern Ukraine and
Crimea
Ukraine has every right to liberate its
territories and people and will continue
to do this regardless of Russia's worlds
or deeds
sham referendum
are elements of aggression against a
sovereign state
and anyone involved in organizing or
conducting these farce will be held
accountable
dear colleagues the resolution has not
been adopted just because of one
negative vote the vote of Russia
we are tired of repeating it again and
again
allowing Russia to Avail itself of the
right of the Soviet Union
to veto decisions of the security
Council effectively prevents this body
from exercising its primary
responsibility under the U.N Charter
maintenance of International Peace and
security
at this very moment millions of people
around the world
see on their screens
the devastating impact of the Russian
presence in the security Council and the
council's failure to effectively respond
to a most pressing security threat of a
global nature
these failure undermines the image and
authority of the United Nations as a
whole
which is unjust
and unfortunate
because the Security Council is only one
pillar of this organization
but the broken one
luckily this organization can still rely
on the other pillars which are
increasingly demonstrating their
determination to step in and use their
potential to the maximum amid the
situation in the security Council
I Avail of this opportunity to again
convey the words of appreciation from my
president
for the secondary General's clear
position
and strong statement that he delivered
yesterday
a statement of integrity
a statement of commitment to the U.N
Charter
a Beacon of Hope for the UN membership
I quote
it cannot be reconciled with the
international legal framework
it stands against everything the
International Community is meant to
stand full
it flows the purposes and principles of
the United Nations
it is a dangerous escalation it has no
place in the modern world it must not be
accepted said the Secretary General and
the quote
but let me pose a question here dear
colleagues
what if the Secretary General was not a
person of the highest moral standards
and was not so dedicated in the course
of defending the charter
this question is not a rhetorical one
we have seen secretary generals of
different calibers and backgrounds
we all remember dark hammershot
who defended the UN U.N purposes and
principles and was never intimidated by
Moscow by moscow's direct threats to him
yet they were secretary generals who
hesitated too long to act to prevent
major crises
today many of us called upon the Russian
ambassador
to respect the U.N Charter
but let me ask again
why should the Russian Federation
respect the charter
that was not followed when letting it
occupy the permanent seat of the Soviet
Union
most of you have already heard on many
occasions the Ukrainian position on the
illegal occupation by Russia of the
Soviet seat in the security Council
but let me quote to you the Russian
confession
of bypassing the rules of admission to
the membership
posted on the U.N official website
and I quote
in fact the whole process
outwardly looked like a simple change of
the country nameplate
at the table of delegations in the
general assembly and in the security
Council
instead of the Soviet Union plate
the Russian Federation appeared
end of quote
said right in our face the Soviet Envoy
in you to un in 1991 Julie varnsov
ladies and gentlemen
not a single vote not a single formal
decision
neither in the security Council nor in
the general assembly
just a notification by president yelson
delivered today to the then Secretary
General
delivered to the addressee by the Soviet
Ambassador warrensov as an ambassador of
a new member State the Russian
Federation
we will never have secretary generals
of this organization who execute the
vicious of Russian presidents and admit
new members behind closed doors and
without decisions of the security
Council and the general assembly
what is next you may ask
attempts by Russia to manipulate the
procedures of the general assembly to
redraw the political map of the world
as we may see soon
in the coming weeks
we should not tolerate this legal
nihilism and the aggressor's presence in
the seat
of a permanent member any longer
the absence of the necessary treatment
has turned Russia into cancerous tumor
in the body of the security Council
it has to be removed before in the
entire U.N system is metastasized
it is time to act
if this council is incapable of acting
with Russia
it is your duty to act without it
and let me thank all of you who have
demonstrated during the vote today
your Readiness to act as responsible and
committed members of Security Council I
thank Albania
France
Ghana
Ireland
Kenya
Mexico
Norway
United Arab Emirates
United Kingdom
United States
I thank everyone who rejected the
Russian negative vote
to the benefit of this Security Council
to the benefit of the entire
organization
to the benefit of International Peace
and security and I thank you
declarations
[Music]